Welcome home, master.
Young lady.
Hello!
Look out behind you.
I'm quick on my...oh my gosh, that one scared me.
Reign of balls!
I don't like that one.
Welcome to the game of Sisyphus.
It's a calm, totally not rage-inducing game.
I...I know this game.
There was two...
It was Korone and somebody else.
That they raced against each other.
And...
Korone got like...she like beat it.
And...the other member was like so, so far behind.
Asuki.
That sounds correct.
Yeah, they were like racing against each other.
And Asuki was...
I'm a new viewer.
Good to see you.
Thanks, train man.
What's your most unhinged opinion?
Unhinged opinion.
Don't get my Oshi cancelled.
No!
It's not unhinged though.
Your birthday?
Winter Cedar, happy birthday!
Say it.
No, I was going to say...
Sorry, I'm really racking my brain about this.
I'm not delaying starting this game at all.
No.
I don't know!
No!
I was going to say ketchup and eggs.
It's not unhinged at all.
Maybe.
It's normal.
It's normal?
Wait, what about ketchup and mac and cheese?
I think I'm just hungry.
And Draco thinks that's what he gifted.
That's unhinged?
It's not even though.
Oh, I know!
Maybe... Well, it's not unhinged, but...
I prefer stale popcorn to normal popcorn.
Maybe that's my... I don't know if that's unhinged enough.
Mia had requested months ago for a record time of beating this game.
Did she actually... Did Henya actually beat the game?
Oh yes, I'm playing a game today.
I'm playing this sissy game because my kamioshi, Henya the Genius, said you must play this game.
And I said I would do it.
Did I say when I would do it?
No, but...
I did say that I would play it.
And I brought up Korone and Asuki before because they... I think it's really only their playthrough that I ever watched of the game.
Because I was just watching poor Asuki cry.
That's so sad.
I'm not stalling.
This is how long I always take before I start games.
Her craziest opinion is that she actually loves Hayley Jelosman.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my gosh.
I forgot to sing Happy Birthday.
Wait, hold on.
Let me go up.
I'm so sorry.
Hold on.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Winter Cedar!
Hold on.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Winter Cedar.
Happy birthday!
Okay.
What do you mean it's not their birthday?
My unhinged opinion is that the moon...
That's an opinion.
Reread.
Oh, am I stupid?
But someone... Okay.
Someone said Happy Birthday.
Honestly, if you guys respond to someone...
I see that more better than if...
If I miss the super chat.
So I'll see people responding to a super chat.
And that's usually how I know if it's a birthday or not.
So if you guys say Happy Birthday to a super chat...
That's how I'm going to...
That's how I'm going to do it.
Let me see.
Okay.
Oh, today isn't my birthday.
Well, I sing you a happy birthday song, so...
So...
But congratulations!
You guys are now making me throw out birthday songs willy-nilly.
It's a sacred thing you can only give once a year.
Please.
Sorry, every time I click out of the game...
The music stops.
So, it's everybody's birthday.
Not today.
Not today!
Well, yeah, you used yours for this year, Winter.
So sorry.
Like any more viewers than days in a year, there are several birthdays every day.
I mean, I do sing pretty much every stream, I think.
Can you wish my friend Weepin'?
Are you guys just saying that now?
Wait, is it not their birthday?
Today is not my birthday.
Will you sing happy birthday for me anyways?
No!
Am I supposed to sing?
Stop saying happy birthday to everybody!
You guys are seriously going to ruin the system.
I should have never told you.
Now you guys are ruining it.
Can we just pretend it's my cat's birthday?
My cats before stream were going nutso.
Freakazoid mode.
So, one thing about Butaro is that...
That guy is kind of a bully.
My cat Butaro is kind of a bully.
And Paws is so sweet.
She's just like a sweetie baby little princess angel.
I love her.
So aptly named.
Truly.
And...
He's just...
Nice to meet you.
I've seen clips of you here and there.
I haven't properly met you.
You're adorable.
Glad first live words I heard was your preference for stale popcorn.
So many new people today.
That's also another reason I wanted to play this game.
I felt that many...
Maybe too many clips were coming out about me...
You know, crashing out...
And cracking up.
I haven't cracked up in a while.
Rather, I need more clips of me cracking up.
Because I haven't cracked up in a while.
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
It's not my birthday!
So I was just like, if I play a Rage game...
And if I'm totally super duper cool...
I mean, look at my glasses.
This is the coolest I could be.
But if I'm wearing my glasses...
And I'm acting all calm and cool and collected...
And I don't rage a single bit...
Then people will maybe also make a clip about me.
And they're just like, wow, look at...
In the face of adversity, look how she handles herself.
You know how there's the said calmly meme or whatever?
That's me, but facts.
It's not my birthday!
Stupid!
07, Taminto's vocal chords.
That's another thing.
I need to preserve my voice.
I need to stop screaming about everything, okay?
I need to save it for special moments, like Metal Gear.
Why'd you call me a pervert?
No, I said preserve.
Wait, what did I say?
No, I didn't.
I said...
I said preserve, right?
No way!
Wait, this isn't actually a birthday?
I'm scared to check now, everybody.
Happy birthday, Taminto.
It's not my birthday!
My birthday is in August.
No, you have to wait, Spank.
I'm looking forward to a generational crashout.
I didn't say pervert!
And if I did, I'm talking about you!
Only a pervert would hear the word pervert come out of my lips.
I'm scared for the clip.
I'm gonna unarchive this.
Stop, I'm already crying.
I already have tears in my eyes.
Stop it.
I need to pervert my voice.
No!
I said preserve!
Like the jam!
Like a jelly!
Please understand.
I have a special announcement.
Hi.
Anyway, I was talking about my cats earlier too.
Hi, dog.
I'm not crying because of the game.
Not yet.
I'm gonna start the game and then I'm gonna talk about my cats.
Only a pervert trusts his life to a woman.
Also, white sister Rhyme, welcome back for two months in you!
I have to get gold.
I wanted the apple.
Okay, we'll have to...
A dog!
We'll have to aim for it.
Happy birthday Minto's mustache?
No.
I don't have one, do I?
Do I need to shave my stunning beard?
Did you guys notice it on stream today?
Did I not shave so that you could see how great my beard is?
Okay, we move here.
We run here.
We jump here.
Why do I need to jump anyway?
Camera zoom.
Oh, camera zoom.
Why am I naked?
I got an achievement for starting the game.
Chat reflects the streamer.
Here we go!
So if I like...
If I wanted to...
Okay, if I wanted to push it to the left...
Okay.
No, no.
I'm just testing it out real quick.
No, don't go that way.
Wait, don't go that way.
Stop.
Wait, no.
Why is it so kind of ASMR, so crackly?
No, stop.
Go up.
Why does it have like crazy physics?
It like just moves on its own.
Why am I moving diagonally?
Stop.
Why does it have drift?
What is this Joy-Con drift that it has?
Wait, there's an exit.
It's still going!
I don't think this is how it works.
I was only pushing it diagonally because...
I don't think this is how...
Shouldn't it...
Inertia?
What is happening?
Why does it keep moving?
Rolling girl.
One more time, one more time.
It's a very haunted ball.
What's E?
It keeps telling me to do this.
Push and push.
Let's keep going.
I'm not trying to push it diagonally, you guys.
I'm literally pushing straight.
And it's doing this.
I don't know how to change it.
I'm literally only pressing W.
I'm pressing W.
Mouse buttons.
Wait, what?
What do you mean mouse buttons?
Roll boulder left.
Wait, what?
I thought it meant left and right as in like...
Okay, hold on.
Ah, I see.
So that's how you balance it.
I got it now.
Okay,
anyway, we do need to go a little to the right.
Never mind, to the left.
Take it back now, y'all.
One half this time.
Slide to the left.
Slide to the right.
Criss-cross.
I feel like I'm worried that it will be hard to see the Super Chats and apologize in advance.
Oh my god.
I got it.
No!
I thought we had it.
I was talking about my cats.
So, Butaro is a bit of a bully.
And he...
Don't worry, I'll get used to the controls and we'll be like super, super good.
Nanomachine boulder.
And so they'll fight because Butaro wants to be licked, right?
He wants to be licked by Paws.
Because he's just a little freak like that, you know?
Oh wait, I did the wrong direction.
There we go.
And so after they fight...
Like 9 times out of 10, I'll also see him take over her spot.
You know?
Oh, I pressed right instead of left.
It's fine.
We're okay.
And so, this guy...
This stinking guy...
Also is very... He's like a possessive freak.
He's so rude.
Oh, left, left.
Wait, oh shoot.
I messed up.
Wait.
When you're like pushing one way, you have to press the mouse a different way.
Didn't you say he's a chill guy?
Not really.
Cat reflects the streamer?
No, what do you mean?
See?
I didn't press left hard enough.
Oh yeah...
But everybody struggles this much in the beginning, right?
Right?
Okay, here I go.
Why are you especially slow all of a sudden?
Right.
Left.
But also...
Right, but left.
So that's how you balance it out, you know?
Oh gosh, I'm...
How do I...
Right, right, right.
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
Buddy.
Even it out, even it out.
I don't wanna go this way!
I don't...
Okay, okay.
Alright.
Okay.
We'll just...
The music is kinda nice though, I like it.
I hope I don't get copyright struck.
You'll go where the ball takes you.
I'm taking it nice and slow.
Slowly, slowly.
Okay.
Slowly.
Gosh, I feel like I can't reach out at all.
I feel like I have to concentrate everything.
I can't even scratch my face.
I have to have all hands on deck.
I have to be fully focused.
Fully in the zone.
I like this music.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot.
It's way better than getting over it.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
You can stand still.
Oh, shoot.
But it's kinda dangerous too, I'd say.
Okay.
Alright.
Left.
Alright, nice.
Gotta get a little bit of hurdles here.
We're okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, left, left, left, left.
Left, left, left.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Right, right.
Left, left.
Right, left.
Right, right, right.
Right, right.
Okay.
Oh, left.
We got this.
I got my A.
Yeah.
I'm locked in.
I am.
Kind of.
Maybe not as much as I should be.
Don't look at ya.
I can't look at you guys.
This is my punishment.
Oh, I miss you guys though.
What are you guys saying?
What are you guys doing?
Are those logs?
How do I get past those?
No way.
There's a little tiny ramp.
Are you kidding me right now?
No way.
Game.
This is the first level.
How many different area zones are there?
How many are there?
No, no.
No, no, no.
No.
Okay.
Come on.
99?
Shut up.
Seriously?
Well, I wonder what a speedrun of this game looks like.
Okay.
No, no.
I lost my ball.
I
like how he cried.
We were so close.
That part's so tricky.
Can I hop over this?
Actually, how do I get through?
Does it open up?
I wish I could also roll to the bottom.
We can't cheat it.
Says you.
Okay, thank you for the ball cam.
Thank you, I hear it.
Oh yeah, it's very crunchy rolling down there.
Oh yeah, it's very crunchy.
Alright, we got there.
Yeah, ball cam.
Okay.
Alright, we're back.
I had a little bit of a respite.
It was pretty nice actually, I'm not gonna lie.
Just being able to walk normally with nothing to worry about or anything.
What's the quote about the Sisyphus that must imagine him happy?
What's the full quote?
Is it because you just can't, you'll be too sad if you think about his eternal pain?
Oh, it's an entire essay.
He might be.
He might be happy, who knows.
I think I got pretty far though.
I think I almost beat the game with that one, not gonna lie.
Now, what if I don't make it through the next one?
Rather, what if I mess up and then it goes all the way back to the beginning?
One must imagine Sisyphus freaking out.
True.
What the?
I can't see in front of me, it's a little difficult.
If life is a repetitive grind with no real end or objective, and Sisyphus can't be happy with his repeated unending task, what hope do we have?
Murphy getting real.
I'm dead, so good luck everybody else.
Stop, I read Murphy's, I know it's not his birthday.
You can't fool me.
Oh my gosh, I did not see that.
I did not see that at all.
Oh, I wish they could have made this dang boulder a little smaller.
Just make it really dense.
Just make it a really dense boulder, you know?
But like small so I can see over it.
I'm slowly navigating.
Oh my god, I did not mean to jump.
My thumb got a little too relaxed there.
It's a beach ball.
It looks like the moon.
Like it's very smooth.
Looks like your brain.
Oh my gosh, we could get a mod, oh my goodness, where it's a wisp, you know?
That'd be...
Okay,
we made it, we're fine.
We have ultimate controls over this thing, kind of.
Okay, alright.
Oh gosh, alright.
We're coming back to where I originally... Oh no!
Easy.
Slow and steady.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
No!
Oh come on!
You almost stopped!
Please!
Parkour.
What do you mean something goofy?
What's happening?
What did you say?
Oh, would you say something goofy for that much money?
I say goofy things for free!
What?
Okay,
here we go.
Now we get to do it all over again!
I am calm.
I'm good.
What was Henya's time?
Does anybody know?
If anybody wants to look it up?
I'm curious to know as well.
What her time was?
Oh, maybe being at a diagonal is not the strat.
I just wanted to see what was in front of me.
Diagnovable.
Seven hours.
Fake fan.
It's the hard thing about being a VTuber too, is I don't get to watch streams as much.
But you know.
Also, I venture to Twitch like once a week.
So...
If she ever decides to cross stream, then...
Also, we stream at quite similar times.
She sometimes is a little later than me, but sometimes I get to catch like...
If I'm not streaming on a day, then I can usually be able to watch at least a little bit.
Just imagine how hard this game would go in first person mode.
Twitch is rough for non-subscribed channels.
Oh my god!
It's actually the worst.
I got a five minute ad once watching her.
This was the other day, so it's like fresh in my mind.
I got a five minute ad.
And then, not even 20 minutes into her stream, I got another five minute ad.
And I was like...
I can't...
I was like, I only watched 20 minutes.
What do you mean that I am already getting another ad so long?
And I would subscribe.
You know, maybe I should just subscribe to her.
I don't watch because, like I said, I don't go on Twitch very much.
But I enjoy her enough that I don't mind throwing money at her all the time.
But oh my gosh, it's just horrible.
That's why you won't find me on Twitch.
As much as some people are like, I don't like YouTube's chat.
And I do think that YouTube's chat is not great.
And then there's like some...
What's it called?
We miss out on like fun integration stuff, which makes me sad.
But...
I just hate Twitch so much.
And it sucks because like my friends are on Twitch and I sometimes go to watch them.
Oh my god!
No, no, no, no, no!
Wait, oh my gosh.
Oh, I thought I was going to stop.
There she goes.
Blame Twitch for this.
Yeah, Twitch threw off my groove.
I just wish YouTube would like...
Give a damn.
And like try to improve the YouTube streaming.
But now especially I think since a bunch of the bigger streamers are going back to Twitch.
Because YouTube had literally everything in the palm of their hands.
And then totally blew it.
I don't think they'll care at all.
It's so sad.
You dropped your giant ball.
I don't have multiple balls, not balls.
Only one.
I fumbled it so hard.
I know, it's so frustrating.
I still like watching on YouTube better overall, so I'm glad you're here.
I do too.
I forgot to get a drink.
Oh no.
But at least there's the cross streaming.
I just hope...
I just wish maybe more people did it.
But I get it too, because it's like, you know.
Then you're splitting audience.
I don't know.
Whatever.
I was watching stream and I had a tooth fall out.
What?
Kinky?
It was fun to raid Matara.
Yeah, I never get to do that.
So that was fun.
I still don't always remember the raiding as a feature.
Like at the end of the stream.
I'll get raids throughout stream and I'll be like, oh, I should raid somebody.
But also, like, I don't know so many people on YouTube.
And then sometimes, you know, if somebody doesn't have their raids turned on, you know, I can't do that obviously.
Wait.
It took seven hours.
Jeez.
I like, I don't...
I don't really enjoy rage games.
Like I enjoy challenges in a game, but yes, usually if it's like...
You know, a notoriously difficult game.
But I don't enjoy necessarily...
Like, oh, this game was built to be challenging, but not in a way that's like...
You know, it's like...
Like, I don't know.
I don't feel like I'm developing any skills.
From playing this.
Does that make sense?
Twitch is so awful, its entire staff is...
Oh my gosh.
Why don't you and other Vtubers have the DBR on?
That's because...
Usually, I'll get, like, people who are behind.
There's a couple of reasons.
One is, like, people will come in and they'll be, like, behind the stream.
And then the chat will be also...
Like, they'll be chatting.
But they'll be chatting about something from, like, ten minutes ago, you know?
So that's one reason I...
Keep it off.
Hold on, hold on, I really need to concentrate.
Hold on, sorry.
Sorry.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Oh gosh, I'm all the way over here though.
Hold on.
Oh gosh.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, stop.
Stop.
Okay.
But another reason is...
In case something messes up...
Or something accidentally shows...
People can't, like, go back and...
Screenshot it.
It's so far over!
It's all the way over there.
Slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Slowly, slowly.
Slowly.
Slowly, slowly, slowly.
Slowly, slowly.
Slowly.
Oh my gosh, this part's gonna be freaking impossible.
Oh my gosh.
This part's gonna be so difficult.
Slowly, slowly, slowly, slowly.
Slowly, slowly, slowly.
Slowly, slowly, slowly...
No, no, no, no, no, please!
I'm cool, I'm calm.
Why are you going over there?
You're trying to sabotage me.
How many areas did you say?
There's not 99.
That's impossible.
I'm googling it.
How... Game of Sisyphus.
How many areas in Game of Sisyphus?
There's 29!
You liars!
Oh no.
How is anyone supposed to do these?
Excuse me?
99, my ass.
This is what happened before!
Oh, I just need to hold...
Okay, I think I just need to hold...
I needed to hold...
I needed to hold right...
Back in the center.
60 FPS max.
Yeah, why would I need it to be any more?
YouTube doesn't even show...
I'm streaming in 1080p.
Why would I push my computer anymore?
Yeah, it's quaking in our boots right now.
Why?
Because I'm so good?
Because I'm so good at this?
It's been an hour and I'm only on level 1?
Yeah.
I'm a god gamer?
I saw some people say F.A.N.A.
only took one hour, so...
I'm not the goddess gamer.
Why is chat so obsessed with FPS?
Because high number is exciting.
High number means better.
Always.
Yes.
One hour without the ball?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that?
Freaks per second.
That's why chat is obsessed.
Oh my gosh, 60 freaks per second is...
Actually...
You might need to go see a doctor.
Oh my gosh.
Leave the rock behind, do it kidding style.
What do you mean?
I wanted to send...
What I wanted to send was too long, so you can have my first August number because you're a little freaky.
No!
Wait, what do you want me to say?
Mike Tyson!
Thank you!
Can I push it up?
Over this?
No.
Dang it.
Thank you for the first number.
No way.
Thank you!
I'm honored.
Oh my goodness.
I almost lost that actually.
Okay.
Happy birthday legend.
What did you want me to say?
She ran to the top without the rock.
But how?
How did she get over the fence?
Oh my goodness, oh my goodness, oh my goodness.
We're good.
We're chill.
Gamer.
See, that's what I'm saying.
She's the ultimate gamer.
Oh my goodness.
This part is scary because I'm not...
Clear!
Do I just go in?
I just lost it.
The game is kind.
How the heck?
And there's like... Hold on, can I leave you here?
You stay.
What are these?
This is... The game is not kind.
The game is not kind.
Excuse me?
It looks like the music makes it sound so lonely.
This game is evil!
This area is huge.
What?
We're scoping out the area first, guys.
What the heck is this?
This is so evil.
Here.
How do you even get past the fence?
Go out of bounds.
Let's go get my ball.
Can this hit me?
I'm faster.
Oh my gosh!
Can this hit me?
Oh, come on.
I can.
Too short as usual.
Wait a second.
Go out of bounds.
It's just a fence.
It's just a wooden fence.
Break the game.
There is no escape.
This one seems longer than the previous one we just did, I'm gonna say.
I'm gonna say this one seems longer.
What's underneath anyway?
I'm scared.
I'm truly frightened, actually.
Is it actually a birthday?
I've been having a rough day, so I'm glad you're streaming.
No, Cyber!
Let me have a better day!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Nicholas.
Happy birthday!
Alright, we'll make it through.
Make
it through.
We gotta get to the other side though, I think.
Alright, look at that sweet, sweet diagonal action.
Did you guys see that?
Okay.
Oh, did you guys see that?
That sweet, sweet... that was clean.
That was clean, wasn't it?
Stop, Cyber!
Cyberfishing did not say it's a birthday.
Wait, thanks for the birthday wishes.
Wait, is it your birthday?
Did I not read it?
Sixty FPS diagonal.
No!
Stop, you guys!
Jeez!
Cheese.
Cheddar.
We're okay.
Alright.
How do we make it through this one?
I
think I...
Maybe I can go through the middle.
Carefully.
Yes.
Let the obstacle help.
Middle.
Cinto.
Mia.
I feel like I haven't seen you in a minute.
I hope you're good.
If you've been around...
Sorry, I'm bad at looking at names in chat sometimes.
Pause near the plunger.
Okay.
Stefo, thanks for nine months!
Minky, please.
That's because I'm reading your actual messages!
I've been getting an education.
What have you... Teach... Tell the class what you've learned.
Tell us one thing you've learned.
Pretend you're giving a presentation.
Oh my goodness.
We saved that.
Good job, guys.
I wish I could see it when it's long.
Like when it's pushed out, you know?
It should have a little something on it.
I don't know.
Like a little flag.
Ball is life.
Eternal life.
We love the orb.
Our little ball.
Look at him.
We're using that as a support.
Oh yeah.
This is a great thumbnail.
I kind of want the ball, but with my face on it.
Good luck.
Thank you!
Okay.
Let's go.
It pushes...
a little fast.
Go!
Got it!
Diagonal slide.
There we go.
I think I can make it on the right, right?
Against the wall?
Can I make it against the wall?
I think so.
Yeah!
Nice.
Oh gosh.
Okay.
We're good.
Alright.
Onwards!
Okay.
Nice!
We can make it past these guys.
Okay.
Nice and easy.
Slow and steady.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Get it twisted.
Why are you telling me?
What am I getting twisted?
Don't get it twisted.
This is a little obstacle.
Right here.
Okay.
We overcame.
We are truly the overcomers.
Okay.
Here.
I wish I could put my ball somewhere.
Wish I could just plop it down.
It's from a Northern Lion stream.
Who is that guy?
Wait.
I feel like I'm learning about Jerma all over again.
Which I still don't even really know who that guy is.
So...
Yeah, I know it's fun as Oshie.
I just don't know anything about him.
Oh, Nimi likes him too.
He is bald Jerma.
It's just like Jerma.
So you're saying Jerma is not original.
You're saying Jerma is...
You know, the way everybody talked about him, he just seemed like the...
Like the end-all be-all streamer.
And that he was the most original man in the world.
But you're saying that he's not.
Oh, of America.
And then Jerma...
Then Northern Lion is the Canadian.
Vinny, Jerma, Northern Lion, Holy Trinity.
I only really know Vinny, but I mean...
I watched his, like, game glitch stuff.
I don't really watch his streams.
Don't tell Matara, I guess.
Since I know Matara is friends with him.
Jerma equals Minto.
Northern Lion...
Lion.
It almost, like, sucked in my throat there.
Northern... It's a hard name to say.
Northern Lion.
Okay.
Guys, I have to focus!
We're about to come up upon a tricky situation.
First, I need to...
First, I need to get over.
Okay.
It's quite slow, but I'm still nervous.
I'm scared.
We've gotten so far through here.
Let's see the end!
Rude!
Yay!
Okay.
Alright.
I need to get a little closer, I think.
Oh gosh!
You guys all saw I almost one-shot this entire level.
You guys all saw that, right?
I almost did this level!
First try!
I almost did it!
No!
I don't know the timing on that.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Why couldn't it get stopped by...
Why didn't it shoot up straight into the air like past this part?
Where it would've stopped.
Oh, there's two of them even.
Three of them even!
You guys, I have to get the timing perfectly three times!
They all have the same timing though.
What is this
one anyway?
Just rock?
What are the red ones?
Okay, anyway.
Oh, they're explosives.
I love that!
Be free!
This is the first!
Grab on to the tree!
Grab on and pull!
You've got this!
Return to Minky.
He's already halfway there.
He's only got pants on.
You...
I'm so stinkin' stinky.
I'm not stinky.
I'm just, you know.
You know what I mean.
Game is stinky.
Okay.
We did it once, we can do it again.
I just hate how slow it is, you know?
Speedrunners must hate this game.
Don't say that you want to sniff me, please.
Don't say that.
We're good.
Everything's fine.
Oh, here's the one in the middle.
You know, being a Vtuber is such an interesting thing.
I see...
I see so many strange comments about me on the daily.
And I just have to be like...
Yeah.
Like, oh, you guys are so silly.
I see so many strange comments, though.
I'm just like, wow.
I think if...
If this was normal people... Oh my goodness.
No, no, no.
They would probably lose their... They would go bonkers.
They would go bonkers.
They would be like, what's wrong with this world?
I think most people would lose faith in humanity if they saw the things.
How many of those are from Orca?
It's a variety of people.
I see it all on Twitter.
People would be like, I lose all humanity in this world.
Probably.
Okay, nice.
Go past.
Okay, should we tone it down?
I'm not saying that.
I think it's funny.
I'm just saying if like an average Joe were to...
You know, one day be like, I'm gonna become a Vtuber.
Maybe it's also my fault because I've...
I've been like, yeah, freaks.
Rise up.
I'm like Megatron.
I think that's just streamers in general.
I'm sure Flesh streamers also have weird comments about them.
True, but I think also I've encouraged it.
Freak up.
Yeah, pretty much.
I just say, I just, you know, thought about it the other day.
And I was just like, wow.
Wow.
I'm glad my mom doesn't have Twitter.
Or know about my account.
Kind of deal, you know.
Just like that.
Yeah.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Come on.
Come on, buddy.
And just like that, we're back where we were.
Maybe the level wasn't much longer than I thought it was.
Chat reflects the streamer.
Oh no.
Okay.
No, I think I'm gonna lose it again.
One down.
Two to go.
Okay, one down.
Not that I get close enough to where they don't touch it, obviously.
But I can like, get through, you know.
Go, go, go.
Okay.
Another one down.
Nice.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
I'm not ready.
Go!
Sensei, let's go!
Eerie!
Let's go scope it out.
If I touch it myself...
Wait a second.
Wait.
Oh.
Okay, game.
Game.
They respawned.
They respawned it?
What the hell is this?
Wait, this could be... I feel like a lot of speedrunners could use this.
And now you knock the ball way in the front.
What's this next one?
Oh my god!
Don't like that.
I don't like that.
Okay.
This one is... Oh, whoops.
It's just another slow and steady kind of dealio, I think.
I think we'll mostly be alright.
I'm concerned a little bit about the textured road, but...
It could just also be a texture, right?
Ever onward, ever higher, ever better!
Hello rock.
Did you miss me?
It's not a bowler.
It's a rock!
A rock!
Okay.
Really crunchy.
Like...
Crunchy!
Oh my goodness.
Like, super...
This game is actually pretty ASMR.
Rage game ASMR, yeah!
Right?
Like, it's actually quite nice.
I'm gonna try and...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay, we're good.
Yeah, I really like the soundtrack in this one.
I prefer it much more to the...
Oh my gosh, the talking and...
And what's it called?
Is that where I can break out of bounds?
We found the secret!
To the talking and getting over it or whatever.
Turn off the music?
No, I like it!
I'm just talking about how I like it!
Okay.
Oh, you can push your thing faster.
Oh my god, guys.
I think I'm... I think I've been playing hard mode.
I haven't been pushing my boulder fast at all.
Here
we go.
Oh, geez.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
You're gonna explode!
I went
out of bounds three times.
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Oh, thank goodness the catchers exist, right?
Okay,
back to the crunch.
Yeah, and see, now I'm pushing it faster.
I don't know why I didn't think... Oh, I'm just gonna... I should shift.
I should press run and push at the same time.
Instead I've been doing it the super slowliest ever!
Perfect VTuber idol is so pure and innocent would never look up anime girl skirts or have a body pillow of a middle-aged man with eyepatch.
I'm... I'm... I'm no idol!
I couldn't... Oh no, I messed up again.
Catchers!
No, catchers!
Catchers, please!
Catchers, do your job!
Catchers!
Stop there!
Stop!
We're fine!
Everything is okay!
The catchers!
I literally was just praising you!
That could be worse.
I just have to remember how to get through this again.
I have to get through two of them and not mess up.
Push!
I'm starting to lose control over my bodily functions.
Everything is f'ed.
Everything sucks.
Trill.
Trill, trill, trill.
No, we're happy doing this.
Remember?
Imagine him happy.
He's chilling.
He loves doing this.
Wouldn't you?
Hold
on.
Hold on.
I'm trying to get it.
There we go.
Okay, we made it.
I'm actually starting to forget controls.
This is so bad.
Can we sing break stuff?
I'm forgetting to move my mouse and also to press left or press right or press WASDA.
It's not everything.
Why am I losing all controls?
It's like my brain has actually become mush.
The minky madness.
After a few rounds, can we sing break stuff to get the happy energy out?
I can't.
I have to prepare my voice for Friday Jazzy Jazz Jazzathon Jazz Jazzness.
Which I made a set list for yesterday?
Was it yesterday?
ViviCorinthanksforthegifted!
And I have quite a few songs to learn which is why I'm taking off tomorrow so I can learn them.
My brain is smooth.
No, it needs to be like this road.
It needs to be like this road.
I leave Minto at the foot of the mountain.
Hold on, I can't read all of this!
She too concludes that all there is is hot dog.
Wait, that all is hot dog?
Hot dog.
I have...
Brianthanksforthefivegifted!
I have a karaoke on...
On...
Friday.
There might be an announcement.
But...
I have to confirm.
Otherwise the announcement will be another day.
But for those who watched me before I went to heaven...
Sorry if it is karaoke and announcement.
For those who don't know...
That's how I...
That's how I announced my graduation.
Was karaoke plus announcement.
But...
Hold on, I need to stretch.
The cafe henceforth without a manager seems to be...
Her neither timely nor clean.
Each subscriber of her channel, each comment...
I couldn't read the rest, it went too fast.
Thank you.
Karaoke plus announcement, BTS.
I know, I'm sorry!
I just tuned in, you're graduating?
No, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not.
You're not gonna do that again, right?
No, no.
What do you mean three out of two?
Yeah, so...
Yeah, but I don't know.
It might be...
Instead the announcement might be next week.
Announcement, parenthesis, good.
Actually, hold on, let me check and see if they just messaged me about it.
Oh, hello, Blue Archive.
Nevermind.
They haven't, they didn't.
Announcement, cement.
Announcement, good.
Did someone say Blue Archive?
Yeah, I was playing earlier.
And I still had it open.
I was checking on my phone.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, um, what's it called?
I'm not, um...
I'm not, uh, uh, uh, stalling or anything.
Do you think I can go through the corner over there?
No, I don't think I can.
I showed up in YouTube AI told me Minna will graduate.
Why would I announce my graduation on this stream?
Why would I do that?
Why would I be like, oh yeah, by the way guys, while I'm playing Sisyphus?
What's it like?
Extreme crash out, truly.
Oh guys, I'm scared.
I can't push it sideways.
I think we just gotta go.
I think we just gotta go for it.
Oh, oh, no,
no.
Grubba, grubba, grubba.
Grubba.
Okay, slow and steady.
Slow and steady.
Yippee!
I pushed it sideways!
Alright.
Alright, next one.
Next one.
Okay.
I wish they made the other pathways, like, possibly doable, you know, but...
Oh my gosh, this one little guy sticking out.
What am I supposed to do about him?
Right there.
Because we would take up the role of Sisyphus if that happened.
It'd be painfully poetic.
Please don't.
I can 100% guarantee you I am not graduating.
Why?
See, like, if I could sneak through there, it was just also a little difficult.
Okay, still less frustrating than The Sims.
At least I'm playing a game, right?
Hey,
Bellatro is a game.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
That's a sad story.
Sisyphus if he was freaky.
Wait, not Brock, sorry.
Rock to push up that thing.
No!
I was playing Bellatro earlier today and I was on my run.
And I went to go use...
I was doing... I was on one of the...
I was on the boss...
I was on anti-11.
And I was on the boss...
No, sorry, I was on anti-10.
And I was on the boss and the boss was you can only play one hand.
And I had a tarot card that I was like, okay, I'm going to use it on my ace.
And it will turn it into a multiplier.
And I then will have a hand that will be able to get me through it.
And...
Like I was going to be able to get through the boss.
But instead of pressing use on the...
On the ace, I accidentally pressed play.
And it only played the single ace.
And since it was only...
Since it was the boss where you only get one play...
I... I...
I was so... I was so mad!
I was so mad at myself, I almost uninstalled the game.
I was like, no!
No!
Oh my gosh, I was so upset.
It's not that I got needled.
It's that I... Well, I mean, I guess maybe.
But I also just... It was my mess up.
So that makes it even worse.
It was my mess up.
I just like instinctively pressed play instead of pressing use on the tarot card.
I even, when it happened, I quickly closed out of my game.
I was like, what if it didn't save?
What if it didn't save?
But unfortunately, it had.
It had.
Unplugs computer.
Gets off of Wi-Fi.
OK, I'm going to stop stalling.
I'm just going to go for it.
Wait, wait, wait.
That was a close one.
Close, close, close.
That is...
The crowd goes wild.
Holy moly.
That one was so close, I feel.
I was truly terrified for my afterlife there.
My life in game.
What?
I'm scared here.
I'm scared I'm gonna...
OK.
Just a little bit more.
Hot dog!
Hot dog, she's coming!
Concentrate!
Got
the next one.
Oh no!
Break it.
Crush.
And over.
And send you into the ball pit.
Alright, let's see what we got here.
This game is the best representation of a wisp's dating life.
What do you mean by that?
Then once we get through here...
I love the sad ball music.
Lift.
Oh, that's so anticlimactic.
OK, this one doesn't seem as bad.
Let's just send... unless you're like...
That one only.
OK, so if you go the wrong way, that's messed up.
This is why we're scoping out the competition first.
Three down, 26 to go.
Water.
Is it like extra slippery or something?
This one seems really tough, I'm not gonna lie.
A swoop.
Does a literal Shrek come out and beat me to death?
We all be fumbling.
Those denying is a patriot spy.
I believe in you guys.
But if you, like, you know...
If you get somebody else, just make sure that they let you watch Minto, OK?
Just make sure that they're like...
Oh yeah, that funny little green thing you watch.
She's fun.
You know?
You have to make sure she also likes watching me.
And if she's just like, stop watching, then break up.
Break up.
It's a red flag.
Minto?
Green flag.
I'm green.
Hello, funny green thing.
I would like to purchase a rock fact.
A rock fact.
Sometimes the ball rolls and sometimes the ball falls.
It's all part of life.
That's a rock fact.
Can't argue with that logic.
But it also is just like...
I mean, I think I would also be kind of jealous.
I'm not gonna lie.
But I also, you know...
I watch Vtubers.
I watch, you know...
It sounds horrible.
I hate this one.
I'm also just kind of needy, so it's like, I'm different.
Oh, shoot.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no.
Okay, what I meant to say... Okay, hold on.
Let me explain my thoughts before I start going in.
Okay.
Say I was with someone and they watched Vtubers.
No, I don't think I would be jealous.
I think...
I don't think so.
It's hard to say.
But I think...
Honestly, you should just...
This is real talk, okay?
This is real talk.
You should be with someone that will let you enjoy your hobbies.
No matter what it is.
So, unless it's like, you know, murdering people.
That's a weird hobby.
Is Minto going to get emotional?
No.
I'm just saying...
Liking Minto is a...
Crucial, crucial, crucial...
It's like the biggest...
The biggest...
Wrong way.
It's the biggest...
Let me meet her first, okay?
Or him.
Let me meet them first.
Let me meet the partner first.
Let me meet them and I'll give my approval or not, okay?
Minto graduates and we all watch...
Miracle event.
Hamburger.
Are you our mom?
No.
But...
What if they get jealous of my Oshis?
We'll just...
Don't let that happen.
I think if you are, you know, good enough...
If you're like, you know, attentive enough...
They shouldn't get jealous, right?
Okay, alright.
Alright.
This one has a factor that I did not take into consideration.
Which increases the difficulty.
The best kinds of relationships are the ones where you support each other in all areas of life.
Including your hobbies.
Exactly.
By the way, Minto, I support your MGS brain rot.
As you should.
I don't... I would still have it even if you didn't support it.
If you were just like...
I can't keep watching you when you're...
Wasting your afterlife away like this.
With all this brain rot.
And I would say...
The door is right there.
I would say...
How am I supposed to stop that?
When it was involuntary.
I can't help what I feel.
Call it a Metal Gear fetish if you will.
I don't know.
You know, it's just one of those things.
It's just one of those things.
Nice.
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna go through this one.
We're gonna wait for it.
Alright.
Nice and fast over the wood.
That's nice.
How am I doing, you guys?
Actually, am I doing well?
Am I doing well?
Good.
Rock fat.
Okay, let's wait for this.
Roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll, roll.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice suit.
Okay.
I did pretty good.
Fine, I guess.
Okay, macaroni.
More like Tsundere-caroni.
Alright,
we're making it through.
We're making it through.
Put one foot in front of the other.
Okay.
Hold on, I'm gonna wait for this one.
Watching both of your playthroughs of MGS series has pushed me to getting to my best friend slash bro into MGS.
So far, it's been fun watching his reactions of confusion.
Good!
Well, I'm assuming then that you've played it then, right?
If you're making your friend play it.
I'm assuming that means you've played it.
I think this is okay.
And then this one's gonna...
wait.
We're okay.
Wait, no, I have to go this way.
That's right.
Remember we scoped out?
We scoped.
Oh my gosh, this next part is gonna be...
Oh, they're all the quickies.
Nice save, thank you.
Okay, I can probably be a little... you know what, let's just go.
Okay,
alright, next one.
Go!
I might be able to do this one too, but I'm just... I'm not gonna risk it.
There we go.
Good thing I didn't risk it.
Okay, go!
Oh gosh, okay.
Probably take it to the sides, I think.
I have a first date this Sunday?
With a really cute girl who also likes Vtubers.
We immediately started asking about...
I didn't get to finish reading it.
What did you ask about?
What did they ask about?
Oh she's...
Wait, wait, wait, don't reach out.
Go,
go, go!
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Almost first try.
I know, right?
How do I... get it?
How do I move it?
Wait, this is actually a problem.
It's actually stuck.
Oh there we go, I got it.
I'm just gonna stand here?
Alright, there we go.
Alright, alright.
Yeah, that could've been so much worse.
Though I was literally at the very end and that just makes me...
A little salty.
But you know, I tried to go diagonal and then I lost it.
Because going diagonal on a...
Quickly is a little scary, you know?
Like here.
Like this is what I was trying to do.
Oh my gosh, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
There we go.
If only it was more around here that we got flung back to, but...
That's okay.
Okay.
Actually, I don't think I can make it.
I don't think so.
Hold on.
We're gonna wait, we're gonna wait.
Alright, and next one.
Alright.
And there we go.
There we go.
Okay.
Push, push, push, push.
Like, not that way.
Can you not?
Okay, there we go.
No, no, no, no.
Left.
I mean right.
Right.
My right.
My right!
Okay.
I'm not gonna go diagonal.
No.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Please lift up!
Lift up!
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
What if I just push it against the wall?
For extra stability.
How?
I don't know.
It's right there.
I'm working on it.
We're almost there.
I'm doing it again.
Please, please, please!
Into the hole.
Oh, this is not ASMR.
This is negative ASMR.
Sad rock.
I love the sad rock vision.
I don't understand what the...
Is this supposed to annoy you to death or...
Oh my god, next is a cactus.
We go from wet to dry.
Oh yeah.
Wet plop.
I know.
It's the plop, plop, plop, plop.
What's special about the cactus?
Maybe it gets stuck.
Maybe it hurts us.
I don't know.
Rocks are known to be hard stoners.
Or...
They're... Or they're rockers.
You wanna hear the song I made up when I was in school?
The song I made up when I was in school...
Rocks, fossils, rocks, fossils, rocks and minerals.
I'm just gonna continue like that.
I don't remember ever singing Minerals.
I don't remember.
But yeah.
What the hell?
Oh yeah, baby.
Starting off strong.
Is that your first original song?
No.
I make up original songs every day.
Okay, I think it is a little slippery.
Maybe that's what this is supposed to be, an issue.
I make up songs every day.
So I probably definitely made up more before that one.
I sing them all to my cats.
Do you have any songs for your cats?
It's a new one every day.
It's however I feel.
You know?
I don't know.
I've been compared to Linda Belcher from Bob's Burgers.
Which I don't know if that's a good thing or not.
I was like...
I forgot I could zoom out.
Oh shoot.
I don't know if it's a good thing or not.
You know, I just have like an opera in my heart.
And I have to just get it out, you know?
It's just how it is, okay?
Does each cat get a unique song?
Yeah, like I said, it really just depends on what comes out of my brain.
So...
It's not like they have dedicated songs.
It's just like...
Oh, this one I've conjured.
So...
Kind of feeling, you know?
Maybe next time I have one I'll try to record it for you guys.
So you can understand what I'm feeling in my brain.
Okay.
Alright.
This one is just a little slippery.
No, no, no, okay.
Slow and steady.
Hold on, I got an itch.
Okay, I got it.
Oh, I didn't see that rock.
Chill out, chill out.
We're cool, we're calm.
We're cucumber.
We're fine.
Okay.
I feel like this game is gonna dry out the ectoplasm in my eyes and all.
I feel like I can't blink.
Alright.
Okay.
This game feels so much more doable than getting over it, I swear.
I feel like with getting over it I'm aimlessly, mindlessly swinging my little shovel.
Blinky.
For now.
Oh, really?
Am I still in the easy phases?
I mean, we haven't even gotten even close to halfway, so I guess you're right.
Some people can speedrun getting over it in like 30 seconds or something crazy.
I think we're on stage...
Four, I don't know actually.
Come on.
Break it.
No, I kept pressing left for some reason.
I'm sorry, hold on, let me break it real quick.
Break it.
Break!
Okay.
Now go back.
In there, okay.
My middle finger hurts from pressing W.
What the hell?
Are you okay?
Is this like his idle position?
Alright, what's in here?
There's just cactus.
Lonely.
I am so lonely.
I've got nobody to call my own.
Lonely.
I am so lonely.
Okay, so you have to go through this.
And then through the cactus again.
What the hell is this?
Why?
They're trying to kill us now!
This is not...
Wait!
This is not just a normal like...
Oh, you're going through the puddle.
No, now this is actual life or death.
Guys, how did she do it?
How did she break the boundary?
How did she do it?
Hmm.
Concrete block, eh?
Wait.
Like this one up here.
I tried climbing on the other blocks.
Concrete block though.
Wait, can I climb on this one?
Maybe I need the rock.
Kill me, I've done wrong!
I've cheated the system!
Wait, how do I get out?
Okay.
Guys, we're fine.
But can you imagine if I told Henya I beat the game in two hours?
I mean like...
Live boulder reaction.
I'm just seeing, I'm just scoping, I'm scoping.
I'm scoping out the...
I think Sisyphus should've worked smarter, not harder.
You know, I mean...
I think you...
I think he could've...
Oh my god, there's guards here!
This game became Metal Gear.
I wanna know what that trident is up there.
I just wanna see what it is.
Oh my gosh, they really beat you up.
They beat you up.
My rock is so sad in the...
I'm just curious what the trident is.
I'm just curious.
I just wanna see what that is.
I just wanna go see what it is.
Him being too smart for his own good is what got him into this mess.
I actually don't know what the story is.
Why he is pushing the boulder, why he likes it.
Or is he happy?
He cheated death?
Oh, so somebody was salty about it, it seems.
So he cheated death, but they were like...
The Hades?
That's how all the myth stuff goes, you know?
The trident is not the end, right?
Because that would be unfortunate.
In fact, I'll just go to here and then I'm gonna call it.
My oshi told me to play the game properly.
Probably.
My oshi wants me to play the game properly, probably.
But I mean...
What if I took a screenshot of this and was like...
I got this far...
Wait, I can't take a screenshot because it shows my boulder all the way back there.
I was gonna say, I got my boulder all the way here in two hours!
I don't wanna play this game anymore!
I've played this game before!
How do you get over this one, actually?
Sideways jump.
Sideways...
Oh my god, I thought I just heard footsteps behind me.
That's so scary.
What is this, Mario?
How many A-presses?
How many A-presses does it take to...
What the?
Now I can't...
I can't jump properly anymore.
Uh-oh.
Half an A-press.
I can beat this game in half an A-press.
I can do it.
A-press is a press.
You can't say it's only half an A-press.
No, no, no.
Yeah, I get that reference.
What's that channel called again?
I can't remember that guy's name.
He always plays the...
I kinda know how to beat this one.
Actually, I got stuck.
Pen and co-ax.
Yeah!
Oh dang, I thought it was me flying.
Wait, this will be good though, right?
When the ball goes through the...
Through the tar, it gets slow.
I'm like sweaty.
I'm chill, but I'm sweaty.
I don't think I've had enough failure to really be so...
So malding.
People malded this game?
You can solve any problem in life with a big enough rock.
Scary.
But true.
You can build a house with a big rock.
Uh...
You could...
You could eat minerals.
You could find minerals in a big rock.
Is this the one that I'm on?
The murder level?
Am I on murder?
No, we're in cactus.
That's right.
I gotta go through the cactus first.
Oh yeah.
You could hunt with a big rock.
I'm concerned, but the cactus make it look like the ball can't slip through if I accidentally lose control.
If I lose myself in the moment.
Okay, we're almost home.
We're almost home everybody.
Yeah, see?
It doesn't look like it would go through.
Maybe it would bounce off like, um...
Like, what's it called?
Pinball or something.
Arms sweaty, knees weak, arms heavy, mom's spaghetti?
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, this guy does look like Eminem.
Eminem in his tighty whities.
Onwards.
That was a nice little break.
Especially for my middle finger.
Which is so worn out from...
Oh, I hear it.
I hear the sand.
On the right...
Oh, we're about to see what happens I suppose.
I messed up.
I'm good.
I'm clean.
I'm clean!
Mental eating sand ASMR.
No!
Don't tell me about your hobbies.
Eat sand.
No!
Oh, I'm gonna miss the sand when we go along this thing.
I don't mind the sand.
I don't mind it at all.
In fact, I've been going fast.
Have you noticed?
I've been going fast through it.
Alright, here we go.
The tough part.
The actual tough part.
Okay.
Alright.
Who built this?
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Little bitch.
Oh, and this is the worst part.
I have to push it down to go back up.
Can you cheese it past?
Let's try.
I don't know.
I don't think you can, but...
What if we cheese it, like...
Let's see what happens.
Let's see what happens right here.
Wait.
Ouch.
Uh-oh.
Why is it going the exact ways that I need it to not go?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Seriously?
Okay.
Live Minto reaction.
I wish it said that.
I wish it said live boulder reaction, you know?
Okay.
I thought it was going right back to the start.
No!
It would have gotten caught someplace, right?
Surely there... I mean, you would have to be the...
The unluckiest ghost in the world...
For it to go...
All the way back to the start.
You know?
You would have to be, like...
Have negative luck stat.
And...
Negative... Negative luck stat.
You know?
I wish the cactus wouldn't...
Wouldn't block my view.
You would have to be so unlucky...
And have so many...
Things... Unlucky things happen...
All the time in your afterlife.
Or life.
Whoever's... If you're alive while playing this.
Come on.
I messed up my chat.
There we go.
Okay.
Alright.
Nice and slow.
Nice and slow pace.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Please.
I wish I could...
Actually...
I wish I could push it, like...
You know, if I were to get off of the thing...
I wish I could push it that way, you know?
I put live boulder reaction in your live chat.
No way!
Nah, no.
I see it!
What?
Who put a wisp in...
You guys.
You guys!
Hold on.
I just saw the other thing.
It showed up right underneath.
Look at this!
Oh my gosh.
Sorry.
Sorry window sound.
Look!
That looks amazing, obviously, but it looks miserable to push.
Me as a boulder.
You're not a boulder.
You're a rock.
Wow, that's amazing.
Okay, hold on.
Live boulder reaction.
Except screw you!
I don't need it!
Because I'm never going to have that live reaction ever again!
Okay.
Come on.
You son of a...
I'm baloney!
Um...
He's so sensitive!
You're so sensitive.
That's what you should use the blow up wisp from AWA for.
I never got that though.
They didn't give it to us.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Thank
you for coming to the games of Sisyphus.
I hope you enjoyed.
What the fuck?
I'm chill!
All your Oshies like rage games.
I know.
It didn't show up on Twitter as...
as...
as see-through.
I wonder if I saved...
Actually, I wonder.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Where did I save the continue?
I just watched it launch into the air!
Hold on.
I'm going to move you guys and we'll all watch together, OK?
Oh my god!
Is it really going to go back to the very beginning?
Is it going to go back to the beginning?
Is it actually going to do this?
I...
No!
I predicted the future.
I...
Saved!
You guys, that's the first level right there.
That's saved where?
It's the first level.
It's an actual Xen loss.
I can't...
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I called that.
I can't believe...
Do
you guys know that episode of American Dad where it's the episode...
Where Roger asks everybody to roast him.
And then after the roast, he's like cool as a cucumber the whole time.
And then when the roast is over, he takes off his sunglasses and he's crying.
American Dad.
Yeah, I love American Dad.
I think I've seen almost every episode.
I think probably I'm not caught up on the recent season, but...
Because I haven't looked into it, but I've seen like almost every episode of American Dad.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I think...
I think we can still make it.
Wait, hold on.
We can go.
I earned this.
I think I've earned this.
I got like halfway through the game.
I got halfway through the game.
Oh, the live boulder reaction.
But it's not see-through.
Oh wait, I can make it.
I can make it see-through.
There we go.
Good enough.
Wait.
One pixel off.
Cry about it.
It's slightly too wide.
It's OK.
Don't worry about it.
American Dad reference.
Kamiyoshi confirmed.
Don't ask me anything about Family Guy though.
I know no Family Guy.
I can go the distance.
I know a place.
Wait.
No.
I can go the distance.
I know where I'm from.
So I will be strong.
I know every mile will be worth my while.
I can go anywhere without a rock to rely on.
I know, I know a place.
It's a place.
A place where there's a boulder.
It's nice and snug.
Gives you a warm hug.
How do I get over this boulder?
How do I get over this?
Try A, D.
A, D, jump.
Like at the same time?
Oh my gosh.
Running diagonally.
Hold on.
Yeah, I know I got stuck here before because I couldn't figure it out.
Oh my goodness.
No.
Diagonal.
Hold on, I got it.
Wait, so if I like...
What are you talking about from here?
Running towards the fence.
What is this?
You
can go through the gap.
Good.
Like that, but the right way.
Maybe if I try from this side.
Oh!
So close.
What
am I doing wrong?
It's easier if you bring the rock down.
Glee!
I think you can just glitch through the corner.
My name is Glee.
You are so true!
Just play normally with the rock?
You do understand.
It took me two and a half hours to get to this point.
Actually, I didn't even get to this point.
Mods, ban him!
How did she do it?
How did she game?
Run along the fence.
I'm running.
I'm running in slow motion.
Wait, no!
No!
Rock!
You think they patched it?
No way.
No.
When is the last time this game got an update?
September?
Wait, June?
No, it's a Japanese translation.
Minor update.
No.
When did she play it?
I don't see anything as of...
As of a long time ago.
So, you know, I think we are good.
Wait, a long time ago.
Hold on, I'm going to look it up.
I'm looking it up.
Oh, I see.
I see where she is playing it.
Hold on.
Let's see how she gets over it.
She played it in May.
Let's see.
Oh, I see!
She does glitch over it.
Wait, sorry guys.
Let me bring it back.
We watched the pro master do it.
Just jump on top by glitching over it.
Can you?
I don't know if you can hear me, but I am...
I am spamming jump!
Can you hear this?
I'm doing it.
I'm sprinting, yeah.
Do I need to just jump at the same time?
Or jump only?
Spam harder for ASMR.
Why doesn't it work?
Help
me out!
Oh, my chat broke.
I give up.
I suck at the game.
I can't beat the game.
I can't beat even glitching through it.
Break the cycle.
You can be your own man.
You don't have to stay here.
Break the cycle.
It ends with you.
It ends with me.
Uninstall the game.
Uninstall the game!
Uninstall.
Uninstall, uninstall.
Where
are you guys?
There you are.
Otsumita!
Thanks guys!
Sorry I couldn't beat the game at all.
But I think I actually won in life.
After life.
By not doing anything at all!
Yeah!
You won the war!
True!
Yes!
We won the war!
And you know how many... This game is 7 gigs.
So now I have plenty of space for more...
I'm gonna go save a meme!
Yeah!
Otsumita everybody!
Thank you!
I will see you guys when I see you next!
And if there is an announcement on Friday, then there might be.
If not, there is one next week.
Oh my gosh!
And also next week is Valentine's Day!
And I said that next week I'm gonna be only nice to you guys.
So...
You might...
You might get all nice stuff.
Also that aid!
Thank you!
Congratulations!
You won!
I did!
Thanks for the donut!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Promise?
Yeah, it's gonna be niceness week.
Niceness for Valentine's Day.
OK!
Otsumita!
Bye bye!